March of the machine has one of the
coolest car designs we've seen team up
cards characters from across the
Multiverse teaming up on a single card
so here's what I think is the best team
up card for Commander as well as 10 or
so mostly budget cards to go with them
and on top of that a link to a 100
budget commander deck
so without further Ado let's check out
Simone and Dina
[Music]
Simone and Dina is a three Mana Soul tie
3-4 human dryad that says whenever you
draw your second card each turn Target
opponent loses to life and you gain two
life it also has tap sacrifice another
creature draw a card you may put a lan
card from your hand onto the battlefield
tact if you control eight or more lands
repeat this process once
now I've already stated in one of my
earlier videos that the soul tie color
wedge is an amazing combination of
colors as it can do nearly everything
powerfully scattered creatures the best
removal in the game the best protection
in the game it can easily ramp it can
draw cards and it can counter spells
so what's the game plan
firstly we want to make full use of that
ability and activate it as many times as
we can and overwhelm our opponents with
value life drain and perhaps a lab
maniac
outside of that we're simply ramping
drawing cards protecting our permanent
and destroying any threats
so first we need some creatures to
sacrifice
rampaging balos xender car's Royal and
sporemound are all the top picks here
and if you already own one well not as
budget friendly as some of the other
cards scoot swarm is perfect here
rampaging balance is a six Mana six six
with trample that says whenever a land
enters the battlefield put a 4-4 green
Beast into play
zendikar's Royal is a five minor
enchantment that says whenever a land
enters the battlefield put a 2-2 green
Elemental into play
and spallmound a five Mana three three
that says whenever a land enters the
battlefield put a 1-1 sapper link to
play
and to wrap it off scoot swarm a one one
for three that says whenever a land
enters a battlefield under your control
create a 1-1 green insect creature
if you control six or more lands create
a token that's a copy of skewed swarm
instead all four of these cards are a
must include in this deck because if we
find a way to untap Simone and Dina they
all provide unlimited fuel for that
awesome ability and would you believe it
there's a card that combos perfectly
who remembers Retreat to the coral helm
there's three Mana enchantment from
Battle for zendikar says whenever a land
enters the battlefield under your
control choose one
you may tap or untap Target creature or
scribe one
so with Simone and Dina in play one of
our landfall token producers and this
enchantment we can infinitely activate
Simone and Dina's ability as long as we
have a land to play from our hand
but given the fact you should be drawing
two cards per activation it shouldn't be
too much of an issue
another excellent landfall creature to
pick up is tireless provisioner a three
Mana three two that says landfall
whenever a land enters a battlefield
under your control create a food token
or a treasure token
because the lands we put into play with
the Simone and Dina's ability come into
play tapped Tyler's provisioner gives us
a way to generate mana and continue
casting spells in between activations
of course if you're lucky enough to have
one of these amulet or Vigor alleviates
all of these issues
Amulet of vigor is a one Mana artifact
that says whenever a permanent enters
the battlefield tapped under your
control untap it
so all those lands that would come into
play tapped get untapped allowing you to
use them straight away
unfortunately though amulet is a 30 card
however you could always pick up Stone
Cedar herofant to do practically the
same job at just 50 cents but it's a
little bit more clunky
[Music]
the last couple of budget cards I'm
looking to pick up are the cards that
say whenever you draw your second card
each turn do something
let's quickly go over the main three I'm
eyeing up
first we have Min Wiley Illusionist a
three minor one three that says whenever
you draw your second card each turn
create a 1-1 blue illusion creature
token with this creature gets plus one
plus o for each other illusion you
control and whenever an illusion you
control dies you may put a permanent
card with minor value less than or equal
to that creature's power from your hand
onto the battlefield
next we have joral mawan villai recluse
a two Mana one two that says whenever
you draw your second card each turn
create a tutu green cat creature token
and for four a green and a green until
end of turn creatures you control have
base power and toughness XX where X is
the number of cards in your hand
and finally gixxian Puppeteer a four
Mana four three that says whenever you
draw your second card each turn each
opponent loses to life and you gain two
life and when gixxian Puppeteer dies
return another Target creature card with
Mana value three or less from your
graveyard to the battlefield
so both men and joral both create
creatures for us to sacrifice to Simone
and Dina's ability and they also both
trigger off their ability too so there's
a great Synergy there
Min can also let us effectively Flash in
permanence for free as long as we have
enough Illusions and a sacrifice Outlet
on the other hand Jarrell allows us to
potentially end the game by buffing all
of our creatures base power and
toughness equal to the number of cards
we have in our hand
throw in a Primal Rage or old One Eye to
give our creatures trample and we
probably have lethal for the whole table
geeksian puppeteers is just a nice cheap
way to apply pressure to all of our
opponents while keeping our own life
total topped up as we draw multiple
cards in a turn
Puppeteer can also bring back Min and
jaral from the graveyard if needed
last but not least three other cards
I've got my eye on thought reflection to
draw a bunch more cards Retreat to hagra
to drain life from our opponents and
Awakening Zone which gives us a bunch
more sacrifice further or ramp depending
on what we need
as I mentioned I've built a 100 budget
commander deck for Simone and Dina and
there's a link to the full deck list in
the description down below if you like
the look of it don't forget to give this
video a like if you want to see more
Commander content how about you check
out this video here or you could
subscribe to the channel and show your
support
thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you next time